okay I've been playing this quite a bit
at least on stream I caught somebody in
the the chat saying if do I have a
Twitter yes it says it on the on the
stream I have that posted twitter at
chess network or tweet at chess network
is what's written there so Queens gambit
declined let's go here this is so far so
good ponent has their dark square Bishop
outside of their pawn chain do I play
queen bee three pressure on this guy or
do I say you know what who cares who
cares about the pressure the bishop has
oh my night what else I might want to
consider just Queen check and I liked it
enough to do it main reason for this I
know I'm not winning a piece but because
i know the night has to block here
that's the only way to save material but
the main point of it is to obstruct this
sepan i don't know if i could really
make it work but i'm gonna try to so now
what wow I have any choice now what yeah
that's really let's think hard about
that one let's think hard about that one
yeah do I want to capture block with my
king mmm sure ok so the night spin but
just temporarily so now what I think I
chopped and then follow up with Bishop
here unless one day I'll be concerned
with the bishop putting pressure on my
night I don't know if that's really the
case so let's chop here first see how
black will recapture and only then will
I decide what I want to do next so
decision time wherever there's a
possibility for a change in the
structure that right
they're red flag critical moment ok this
is the structure that we're hit with I
might want to consider this this is the
weakest pond that I have and I could
exchange it if I really want to for this
healthier default d5 pawn for black pawn
push keeping in mind however that I am
not yet castled needing two moves before
I'm fully developed Bishop here or c4
has my attention if I'm not careful
maybe a 6b five can be played and with
this that type of structure i can't get
this move in i think i should do it now
before I lose the right to do it this
night is pinned and I think if a
question is thrown to my bishop I'm just
going to chop this night up not waste
any time with retreating and focus most
of my attention on just getting
development in what I would love to have
here is just my king castled and this is
exactly i was talking about so if I back
up and try and continue to be a pest on
this diagonal try and maintain this pin
g5 Bishop back the night could be
playing here hitting my bishop may be
threatening to come here okay maybe it's
quite alright but I just don't even want
to have to deal with it those words that
I just shared right there is another way
you could interpret it is I'm I'm just
being a lazy calculator I just don't
wanna I just don't want to deal with it
it's kind of like you know I just don't
want to calculate it out let's just do
something okay now apparently black was
not wanting to give this pawn up i think
capturing what the Queen was alright and
if I did take this pawn the night could
come back and I think it'd be
uncomfortable for me to defend that pond
I could defend at once you could hit it
again with a rook so anyhow I think I'm
quite all right now
structural damage take on this square
let's go for it take on this square and
then play Queen to c4 with tempo and
then get castled if there's pressure on
my night I defend with my Bishop Bishop
here just want to castle there might be
Queen check on a five I have no choice
if that move is played I got exchanged
Queens but that's okay I'm not really
too concerned about trying to exploit
this King side Castle position I just
want to complete my development another
idea you don't have to just always be
going right after your opponent's king I
got to take here so I don't don't always
just be in this I gotta attack attack
attack now there's other approaches that
you could be having positional
approaches one where you're just putting
pressure on these queenside ponds and
that that's that's what has a lot of my
attention right now should I be
concerned about giving up my light
square Bishop I should I don't want to
give that guy up so might I want to
knock castle I was talking about it for
so much I just want a castle and then
you know everything's going to be safe
but might Mike King be quite all right
on the D to square the answer that is no
if I was able to stop this c5 break then
maybe it would be okay hang on well this
could be a little bit scary I still want
to allow for the possibility to play
king d 2 because that's that's a good
spot if I'm able to retain this d 4 on
the board this d4 pawn on the board it's
going to act as a nice shelter for my
king on the D file and I'm not having to
shoo him away all the way over here on
g1 when I'm on d 2 d 2 if G for a second
I thought b6 and then c5 can be played
but keep in mind what be
six does and does not do it does prepare
c5 it does not control a six which I
could make use of right away and then
take that pond so in short I can play
this move now as far as i can tell it's
going to be okay I could have also
considered maybe rip to c5 maybe there's
just no rush with such a move but um I
have this available I think it's a good
idea to be running with right now so
let's do it because it comes with the
tempo it's looking to follow up with
just doubling on the C file and all of a
sudden it starts to become quite
uncomfortable for this night to even
move because it becoming at the cost of
a seat pond and probably been some so
let's get this in these 6 i'll just take
the two minor pieces for the rook what
else i might be quite alright with
allowing Bishop takes Knight in messing
up my pawn structure I'm going to put
immediate pressure on this night I'm
okay with having double def puns this is
a very valuable piece maybe one of the
best place pieces for black right now is
this bishop in the center watching over
this night pressure on my night on my
king side pond and I'd really like to
get rid of this bishop and i also want
to just get out of this nonsense right
here and this is a has some of my
attention because of Knight to e5 stuff
I want to play here if Bishop takes pawn
that runs into a pin so night here is
right around the corner or I guess I
could consider night h4 with f3 ideas
eyeing this f5 square this is a weak
point let's back up if pawn push well
c6 c7 some issues with that without a
doubt might have to give up my bishop
for the night b5 Bishop back 95 just
have to say so what with that okay the
bishop gets taken for the night and also
I think this as well let's just get
light squared Bishop soft now I really
am without the lightscribe bishops on
the board forget about the night coming
to maybe one of these two which I was
thinking about at one point I would
really love to have him right here so
let's get there extremely inconvenient
to deal with the night on this f5 square
not just because it hits this pond but
there's even possibilities for back
ranked mates I'm on the rook as well and
also there's Forks so that's uh happens
quite easily if the night isn't a good
spot like that so let's get some I could
probably just take this night real soon
and let's take this just crashing
through at this point watch out for the
trickiness no trickiness came here and
then get these ponds going a bit
pressure on this night King up and then
pond plush okay time pressure time
pressure time pressure no time okay good
game good game head let's back up and
flip this board and see if we can take a
thing or two I go as far as saying a
third thing is they're 1313 third team
to be taking away from this um I am not
so sure about the bishops decision to
play to be four so this had this
definitely has my attention right here
because of I think maybe queen a for
forcing this night to obstruct the sea
pond turns out to be pretty good is
there something better you can be doing
right here maybe this is another thing
don't take my night just yet he's not
going to go anywhere and what else I
mean okay the ponds are doubled it'll be
undone by four so I don't know about the
the decision to bring the bishop out
maybe just something a bit more solid
like Bishop e7 or another idea is
anticipating maybe a queen bee three
move maybe you can be playing c6 so as
to me queen bee three with Queen to be
six so you could you can look into that
one as well how about that c6 instead of
bishop out or Bishop to e7 but i'm
really liking I'm really liking the c6
move right here to have a good reaction
to the queen bee three queen bee six
it's just a quick point right there
because this is the structure we're
dealt with I think he I think you
definitely have to take with the Queen
and if pond takes you bring the night
back and then try and recapture it but I
don't know I think okay you're having to
come up with what some difficult choices
here but maybe it starts not to be so or
as difficult if the Bishop b4 move is
employed
so maybe those other other ideas are
worth considering c6 I think gets my
number one vote not saying it's best I
think for me at least I'm much more
comfortable with having a good reaction
to an eventual queen bee three move and
it's also just securing that out that
pond as well on d5 so just some some
quick things keep keep in mind the
things that I'm sharing again I'm not
just directing them at my opponent just
kind of speaking to those that are tuned
in at the moment I like to try my best
to relay it in a way where even if you
are super super new to the game you can
maybe be understanding